[Music]
hey guys vide eighth and final season
being just days away it's the best time
to remember what happened in Westeros
last time you checked enjoy this quick
but detail season same recap at the
twins the remaining Lords of house Frey
are poisoned by Arya
this guy's does bother fray in revenge
for their collision with Lane starts at
red wedding she only left phrase younger
bride to tell the tale
telling her to spread the message the
North remembers the White Walkers march
toward the wall where toilet allows
brain and mirror inside when I fell
despite senses disapproval Jon secures
the loyalties of how somber and Karstark
who fought alongside rams in the battle
the bastards
Jon also receives a letter from Cersei
which she orders seemed to pledge his
fealty to the crown or face her wrath in
King's Landing Jamie tells herself a
crucial need for allies she welcomes
gern who proposed this marriage to her
in exchange for his arm fleet Cersei
declines citing trust as a concern so
your own promises to return with a gift
to prove his loyalty in the Riverlands
arya meets a group of friendly links or
soldiers who take her intention to kill
Circe as a joke tourist shops center a
vision in the fire The Hound sees the
ball and a castle her the dead are
marching past the revelation leads him
to believe in the Lord of Light at the
set adel mastery training similarly
stills books the reveal that the
ancestral seat of House Targaryen gem
stone was built on top of all archers
award dragonglass aka the only substance
along Valyrian steel that is capable
destroying by walkers and sends word to
John he later finds joy in the cell at
the Citadel who is being treated for his
advancing greyscale then he arrives at
Dragonstone the home of House Targaryen
was occupied by Stannis better our army
in dragons the any questions vs. loyalty
and threatens him to burn him alive if
he ever betrays her Melisandre arrives
and encourages her to invite Johnston to
Dragonstone she summons John to come and
bend the knee to her then he also sends
a Dornish man with Yaris fleet to
Sunspear and the US ally to Casterly
Rock
deciding to place King's Landing under
siege grave or maim insanely consummate
their relationship
sir-sir Gators feel lords asking for
their fill tastes and elevating randyll
Tarly as warden of south Qyburn show
Searcy a prototype ballista capable of
harming dragons
after receiving Sam's letter and Danny's
imitation jealous for gemstone II hope
so come in sick Danny to support the
fight against the white walkers but also
to mine journalist he leaves sense in
charge in aggressively warns
Littlefinger to keep his distance upon
learning that joy is son of his former
Lord Commander of the Nights Watch
Cemil applies the forbidden tree mental
endurance greyscale infection risking
his own life and that's when we are
served with this beautiful transition
aurilla meets with hot pie I learned
subgenus ascension to king in the north
holding plans to child he's landing a
nice tent setting course for vinner fell
on her way home Aaron Conners heard I
roll time area who had been living wild
since being sent away to protect her
from Circe's wrath in season one the
mirror leads her own pack of wolves they
had a moment and went separate ways
urines fleet attacks yours Obara Nymeria
are killed
well Illyria turn in your captured film
shows flashes of its time is reek
hesitating to challenge urine before
fleeing the ship by jumping into the sea
John and that was arrived at gemstone
where they meet Tyrion sandy the Trekkie
Danny and her dragons then in demands
his filthy he refuses and focuses
instead of convincing her to fight the
army instead following Tyrians advise
Danny grandson access to the islands
dragonglass
malice and she hides her presents from
Jon and leaves for volantis
brennon rise of NFL and reveals his
newfound role as the three-eyed Raven to
Sansa
brains return was as disturbing for
Sansa as it was comforting bran Stark
died in a cave
what's left is the three-eyed Raven
being the omniscient with Raven meant
dead brain all about his sister she
fails during their separation
his soul Ramsay D - Sansa in King's
Landing urine turns with Larry entering
as a gift for Cersei who promises to
marry him after the war is won
she also rewards him control of her
military alongside Jaime Cersei
administers to tie in the same poison
used to kill Marcella for single area to
watch her daughter impending death in
Oldtown Hilda Jorah leaves to find him
eyebrows forgive Sam oh great warm India
solid attack Casterly Rock only to find
it mostly a band
Jamie led most of the Lancer forces in
the attack of Highgarden
well yours fleet ambushes in his Troisi
on solid ships the Lannister forces
overwhelm alanis army Jamie offers Solon
a quick and painless death by poison
after drinking it she confesses to
poisoning Joffrey hardly returns to
Winterfell
where she reunites with her siblings
salmon brain and spars Brienne where she
shows her exceptional fighting skills
bran unemotionally bids farewell to
Meera divulging that he is no longer the
boy she company toward North
Littlefinger presents brain with a
dagger that was previously used in his
attempted assassination and Branford's
then same with his own climbing the
ladder line
Theon shows up at Jagan stone on a
greater ship and John spares his life
only because he helped sense I escaped
from the Bolton's sir searchers the iron
bank have full return on their
investment as the train carrying gold
from Highgarden is on its way to King's
Landing in the cave filled with
journalist John reveals ancient
paintings to Danny
depicting the first men and the children
of the forest joining forces against the
undead that's convincing Danny that the
night king is their biggest enemy later
Daniel Ernst of the sacking of
Highgarden by the lane stir forces and
realizes her attack on Casterly Rock was
a distraction
despite Tyrians protests she decides to
take action led by Danny riding Geoghan
to the Cheka Cavalry catches the
Lannister army by surprise and Estimator
capture its remaining forces Geoghan is
wounded during the fight by a spear
fired from the Scorpion ballista Jaime's
desperate charge on horseback at the
vulnerable Dania is countered by Geoghan
spewing fire Bronn tackles Jaime into
the river into saving then he offers the
remnants of the Leinster army the choice
to pledge fealty to her or die again
Stearns advised Shias Geoghan burn
Randall etiquette our Lee who refused to
submit Jaime and Bronn returned to
King's Landing then he returns to
gemstone while riding shotgun
John watches as the land and remains
calm even when drogon roars
sensing something in John Geoghan allows
him to get close enough and pet him
much to the surprise of Danny juror
arrives at Dragonstone as well and
reunites with Danny who happily welcomes
him back into her service mr. wall Kane
on brains orders solar John etcetera del
about the whites approaching Eastwatch
Jenna decides to travel beyond the wall
capture what in order to come in sir
safer temporary alliance that was
smuggle styrian inside King's Landing
where he secretly means to Jamie with
the help of his old friend Sir Bronn of
the Blackwater sir same form Jamie that
she is pregnant with his baby
that was three nights again turian
returns him to Dragonstone reckon
Jimmy's journey states that they should
trust each other and fight alongside
chatter just like their fathers Ned and
Robert did although ironically ginji's
father and John's true father were
actual each other's biggest enemies but
a cetera ignoring Watkins letter and
Brants claims several still several
books and leaves a Gillian little Sam
although before that Gil comes across
evidence that Rhaegar Targaryen hit his
marriage annulled and at the same time
married someone else in a secret
ceremony in Dorne at Ventura a little
finger notices sorry spying on him and
leads her to take a letter written by
Sansa from his room John jarring and
rejoined by the Hound of brotherhood and
a group of the free folk led by tormund
leave his torch and pass them all
intending to capture white as an
evidence for Cersei that the army of the
dead is real it's vanilla a little
finger plots to isolate Sansa tensions
between Ari and sense agro following our
discovery of the letter says the scent
as a child begging for Roberts filthy to
Joffrey since the discover star his bag
of faces she took from Bravo's that
Dragonstone Tyrion counsels dannion but
her upcoming negotiations with Cersei
beyond the wall generates a raiding
party to capture why to bring south as
an evidence of why Walker's existence
they're attacked by the white polar bear
which resulted in a few violence killed
and Thoris mortally wounded after
successfully capturing why the group is
then attacked by the night Kings entire
army Jon has gained you return to
Eastwatch and sent her even today need
to request for help
Thoris dies overnight then he writes and
says the group from the whites with the
help of her Jagan's denies King the
leader of the White Walkers through
outside spirit vissarion one of Dana's
dragons and kills it then he flies off
along with the raiding party but is
unable to save John Benjen stark
intervenes and sacrifices himself to a
large on to escape when John and Danny
are reunited John pledges himself and
the north to Danny as the Queen the
night Kings minions bow vissarion's
corpse from the lake the 19 reanimates
bazarian making the jaghana part of the
army at King's Landing the White is
presented to the Lancers
the meeting brought enemies and friends
of old face to face Tyrion and Cersei
Brienne and Jaime Bronn and Tyrion urine
and Theon the hound and the reanimated
Mountain the total game riders did not
have their long-awaited clash but he'll
mysteriously told Gregor that he knew
what was coming for him
he had all his known younger age I
appeared to decide to cut his losses and
run back to the Iron Islands which as we
found out later was a lie and just part
of Circe's plan
Cersei demands John's centrality in the
great war but he upholds his oath to
Danny provoking Cersei to leave Tyrion
meets privately with Cersei apparently
persuading her to Avani Tyrion also
realizes his sister is pregnant
Cersei later reveals to Jamie that she
was lying she is not planning to send
her army north but instead intends to
use the gun company to secure her hold
on Westeros sir civilians flee to bring
them from Essos discuss the Jaime
deserts her in rights nor to help John
and Danny at Dragonstone theone earns
the respect of his men and leaves them
to rescue our at Winterfell finger
creates chaos using arias threatening
demeanor with Sansa leading to a trial
to his surprise Littlefinger finds
himself accused of homicide treason and
betrayal with brain confirming the
extent of his crimes Littlefinger is
executed by Arya little fingers throat
was cut by Arya using a dagger with
which brain was almost killed
despite Littlefinger's machinations the
Starks siblings ended the season United
recognizing that the lone wolf dies but
the pack survives similar reserve and a
fella needs a brain for both the skull
John's parentage they realized Joshua
burnt a Gary named Aegon illegitimate
heir to the Iron Throne as his parents
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark
married in secret on their way to the
north John and Danny MacLeod
it is legend I can rise beyond that
Jeremy's Aryan and collapses a section
of the wall with bluej on fire allowing
the army of the Dead to march through
and setting the events of the final
season that will be our season 7 recap
and now you're fully ready for the final
season of Game of Thrones thank you for
watching and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and they hope to see you in the next one
peace